تم التوقيع في السودان على اتفاق
الايطاليه نصف على تدشين مرحله انتقال
سياسيا جديده يقودها مدنيون لمده عامين
وتنتهي باجراء انتخابات ويهدف الى انهاء
الازمه السياسيه التي اندلعت بعد الانقلاب
الذي قام به الجيش بقياده رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان في
الخامسه والعشرين من شهر تشرين الاول
اكتوبر من عام 2021
ياتي الاتفاق بعد بدعه اشهر من اعلان
البرهان ان الجيش سيبتعد عن السياسه ويترك
المجال الاتفاق على حكومه المدنيه قوى
الحريه والتغيير وهي فصيلا مدني الرئيس
كان انقلاب البرهان اطاح به من بين
المواقعين على هذا الاتفاق الذي كان اعلن
عن التوصل اليه يوم الجمعه الماضي بعد
اجتماع عندما هذه القوى وفصائل سياسيه
اخرى مع قاده عسكريين في حضور مسؤولين من
الاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده اضافه
دبلوماسيين غربيين ونركب ايضا على
استغلاليه ومهنيه وحياديه مؤسسات الدوله
وضروره اصلاحها والتاكيد على مده تفكيك
التمكين الحزبي وبناء دوله الوطن بديلا
لدوله الحزب المجموعات الموقعه على اتفاق
الايطالي في السودان تامل ان يؤدي الى حل
الازمه السياسيه المستفحله التي تعيشها
البلاد منذ اكثر من عام فيما يرى معارضوه
انه يتجاهل مسائل جوهريه ويفتح المجال
امام دخول قوى كانت داعمه لنظام الاخوان
المسلمين الذي اسقطته ثوره شعبيه في نيسان
ابريل من عام 2019